[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
bmx
on connaît désormais les noms des riders
qui partiront aux jeux olympiques de
tokyo cet été on retrouvera notamment
manon valentino joris daudet ou encore
romain mahieu ce dernier sera avec nous
dans cette émission avec l'entraîneur
julien sastre à lire on a 23 ans claire
aurait fait partie des plus grandes
promesses de ce sport en france est
rameuses licenciés à l'association
sportive mantaise va participer aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo cet été avec
l'équipe de france
son portrait golf jean-christophe buchot
a écrit un livre mettant en parallèle le
parcours du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines avec le
développement personnel et détail dans
cette émission avec l'auteur l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ce titre on va
parler à déconfinement il se poursuit
dans les yvelines depuis ce mercredi 9
juin la reprise du sport sans contact en
intérieur est autorisé par les autorités
et la reprise des sports de contact en
extérieur désormais possible les
enceintes sportives peuvent accueillir
5000 spectateurs et surtout les salles
de sport ont pu rouvrir leurs portes
après plus de huit mois de fermeture le
couvre-feu et lui a décalé à 23h
prochaine étape le 30 juin avec la fin
du couvre feu les salles de sport
justement pu rouvrir avec un protocole à
stricte semblable au premier
déconfinement le matériel sera à
désinfecter régulièrement les machines
seront espacés la principale nouveauté
sera la mise en place d'un qr codes à
flasher avec son téléphone à son arrivée
dans la salle pour accéder un cahier de
rappel numérique explication est que ce
gérant de cette salle de fitness à
guyancourt
il suffit de télécharger l'application
anti copie de signal et de cliquer sur
le scan qr code sur son téléphone et il
suffira juste de scanner ce petit qr
codes là en 30 secondes et ça montrera
son passage dans la salle apeler quel
jour tu les salles de sport peuvent
rester route ouverte le soir jusqu'à 23
heures
en tennis vous l'avez aperçu lors de la
finale de roland garros ce dimanche
aurait lié à tour originaire de
versailles a eu le privilège d'être l'
arbitre de chaise de la finale titre 6
passes djokovic remporté par le serbe
une grande première pour cette
versailles est de 37 ans qui a débuté le
tennis avec son père avant de se tourner
vers l'arbitrage dans les prochaines
semaines elle continuera à arbitrer sur
les tournois atp toujours à roland
garros les yvelinois étaient également
présents pendant les trois semaines dans
l'immense contingent des 280 deux
ramasseurs de balle de la compétition
parmi la dizaine divinement retenu pour
cette édition 2021 la plus observée
cyprien marins de magny les hameaux
le jeune de 13 ans a commencé le tennis
à l'âge de cinquante et nice club de sa
ville et il est resté jusqu'à à mercredi
soir dernier à porte d'auteuil il à
ramasser les balles sur le court simone
mathieu sur les annexes il a notamment
été sur des simples hommes et femmes des
matchs junior et des doubles de tennis
fauteuil on écoute justement sa réaction
au micro de tv 78 t-il débrief son
expérience c'était bien si plein de
copains on a vu des grands joueurs
on a profité c'était super sympa je
ramassais les ballots joueurs donc ça va
ramasser les balles qui tombait dans le
filet soit je présentais les balles aux
jambes puis jouer on va maintenant
parler à cyclisme et plus précisément de
bmx
ils s'entraînent tous régulièrement
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la sélection
pour les jeux olympiques de tokyo vient
de tomber chez les femmes on retrouve
manon valentino et axel etienne et chez
les hommes on retrouve sylvain andré
joris daudet ou encore romain mahieu ce
dernier est avec nous en visio pour nous
parler de cette sélection bonsoir
bonsoir et à ses côtés nous avons
également julien sastre l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france bonsoir bonsoir
alors tout d'abord romain j'imagine que
c'est une grande joie forcément d'être
sélectionnés pour ces jo de tokyo
totalement totalement mais je pense que
pour chaque sportif de haut niveau
participe aux jeux olympiques c'est
c'est le plus gros objectif d'une
carrière donc super content ça reste
juste la première étape
maintenant on va y aller pour une
médaille ce qui est équivalent à ce qui
est le rêve est et pourquoi on travaille
tous les jours mais supérieur aux 5
sélections
est-ce que c'est tout surprise ou pas
vraiment finalement romain oui et non on
avait des critères de sélection que tout
le monde était au courant et quitter la
sélection savait ce qu'il fallait faire
donc on pouvait on pouvait on pouvait
savoir où on se situer dans notre dans
notre classement entre nous savoir ce
qu'ils ont dit qu est ce qu on avait
besoin de faire paître sur les courts ce
qui arrivait et voilà juste moi et dont
je dirais pas que c'était une surprise
parce qu'on peut chacun s'y attendait
mais mais ça reste quand même une
je dirais une surprise quand quand
annonce que tu vas faire les jeux
olympiques c'est c'est s'il ya eu des
sélections sur le chemin du monde
championnats d'europe mais de savoir que
tu as par les olympiques c'est différent
votre entourage araji comment justement
super super content pour moi c'est ils
ont beaucoup été là pour moi sur ces
j'irai sur ces vingt dernières années
parce que c'est depuis depuis début juin
a fait plus de 20 ans que chez du vélo
donc sur mes parents mes premiers
entraîneurs
que mon entourage du quotidien
aujourd'hui donc c'était une grande joie
pour tout le monde mais et non je suis
heureux et que tout le monde soit
content et c'est une récompense pour
tout le travail qui a été fourni ces
dernières années julien ça ça se passe
comment une sélection comment on fait
une équipe de france pour les jo
alors déjà c'est entre guillemets
complexe parce que la france a plusieurs
très bons pilotes que ce soit chez les
garçons ou chez les filles donc il ya un
panel un pack très dense et ça peut être
par moment un casse tête et je dirais
qu'il est tant mieux d'avoir d'avoir le
choix c'est toujours c'est toujours une
bonne option
et après quand romain parle deux
critères c'est tout simplement en
construisant les critères de sélection
avec les sportifs ce qu'on a fait à
l'été à l'été 2010 8
et quand roman vous parle de surprise ou
pas surprise banon effectivement la
sélection pour eux n'est pas tellement
une surprise car on a fait le choix de
la régularité avec avec un classement
français interne qui roulait où les
pilotes ont pu scorer depuis mars 2019
et donc du coup voilà on a fait ce
choix-là de la régularité et non pas
peut-être de la forme immédiate au mois
de mai parce qu'on s'est aperçu que
voilà c'est que le c'est très dur a été
l'aspect sur les manches de coupe du
monde ou sur les championnats du monde
donc sur les manches de deux niveaux
mondial et est un gage de performance de
la soirée sur des compétitions comme
comme les jo si je comprends bien il
faut être performant régulièrement
exactement il faut être performant
régulièrement pour vous détailler un peu
le système par exemple les pilotes
apparaissent dans ce ranking dans ce
ranking français à partir du moment où
ils rentrent des finales de niveau
mondial donc c'est à dire en coupe du
monde ou un championnat du monde
s'ils ne rentrent pas de finale sur cet
échelon là ils n'apparaissent pas dans
le ranking et donc entre guillemets ils
ne peuvent pas prétendre à une sélection
donc ça veut dire que pour scorer des
points dans ce ranking là il faut quand
même être très performant parce que
rentrée des finales de niveau mondial
c'est pas donné à tout le monde et puis
bah du coup à l'aller les choses se sont
dessinés petit à petit depuis depuis
mars 2019 et romain mérite tellement sa
sélection seront vous allez romain
mérite plus que pleinement sa sélection
puisque de toute façon il faisait partie
des trois premiers de
de ce ranking et on va dire la cerise
sur le gâteau c'est que sa particularité
c'est que lui par exemple il ya une
piste à tokyo qui lui correspond plutôt
bien qui correspond à son profil et à
ses qualités et notamment et je sais pas
si vous avez suivi cette actualité là
mais lui lors du test event de 2019 on y
allait en octobre 2019 pour voir là pour
un test event à tokyo et ses romans qui
s'était adjugé la victoire à ce moment
là romain vous avez à 26 ans est ce que
c'est le moment de performer lors d'une
grosse compétition comme les jo
peut-être la plus grande compétition
ouais après je pense qu'on peut
performer ce soit ça dépend à 22 ans 24
ans 30 ans on voyait encore des il ya
beaucoup de pilotes maintenant qu'ils
performent et ils ont plus de 30 ans
donc 26 ans à un bon âge après je pense
j'ai encore quelques années quelques
années devant moi mais ce serait ce
serait le bon moment et ce serait bon
moment vous avez réalisé ces dernières
années de belles performances vous avez
terminé quatrième en coupe du monde en
2018 6e en 2019 et 14e en 2020 gagner au
giro finalement ça sera un peu la
récompense de toutes ces années de
régularité on en parlait justement
précédemment parce que les jeux c'est
tous les quatre ans donc on repart dans
le stic à chaque fois pendant quatre ans
prépare c'est juste pas juste pour cette
course parce qu'on a plein de courses
coupe du monde et championnat du monde
mais ça reste le gros le plus gros
objectif donc ramener une médaille
forcément ce sera ce serait une
récompense pour tous les efforts qui ont
été faits ces quatre dernières années
je viens ça sera comment cette équipe de
france
sur le papier elle est complète il ya
brisgau d par exemple une manon
valentino des noms qui parlent en tout
cas romain mahieu bien sûr oui sylvain
andré axel de toute façon sur le papier
cette équipe elle et elle est très belle
moi aujourd'hui j'en suis très fier il
faut pas oublier non plus les
remplaçants qui sont des remplaçants
entre guillemets de luxe on a chez les
garçons par exemple arthur pilar qui est
l'actuel leader de la coupe du monde
2022 après après deux manches camille
mère qui est quatrième au ranking coupe
du monde 2022
donc oui forcément la sélection moi je
la trouve
je la trouve très belle personnellement
si je pouvais me permettre une petite
image un petit comparatif c'est au poker
on parle de cannes flush royale
donc voilà pour moi c'est un peu la can
flush royale
si l'équipe de france a dans son jeu
d'excellente car maintenant et à célèbre
chanteur acteur qui nous dit que
l'important au poker ce ne sont pas les
cartes c'est ce qu'on en fait donc du
coup on va essayer d'en faire quelque
chose quelque chose de bien au mois de
juillet et par rapport aux autres
nations romain vous situer à quel niveau
selon vous on est bon on va pas se le
cacher la france est une des meilleures
nations que on en était à la fin du à la
fin des clés de la qualité qu'on était
premières nations donc on nous on fait
partie des favoris après il ya des
nations comme les pays bas la suisse les
américains qui qui vont avoir la leurs
meilleurs pilotes qui est sûr c'est sur
cette course et il y aura un niveau 1
niveau de jeux olympiques donc donc non
les français sont forts après les autres
nations vont être tout le monde va être
fort sur cette course donc ce sera ce
sera au détail que ça va se jouer
et ouais on va on va travailler à fond
la source sur ce dernier mois pour être
pour être prêt pour fin juillet vient
sastre vous n'aviez pas remporté de
médaille
le bmx n'avait pas remporté de médaille
en 2016 à rio est ce que vous êtes peut
être revanchards cette année revanchard
oui et non oui forcément toujours un
petit peu mais en fait je pense que ce
qui est important c'est que c'est ce que
romain vienne dire c'est que en fait oui
l'équipe de france a du potentiel
par contre lui les adversaires en face
au rpt ont du potentiel également on
sait tous et toutes que les compteurs
seront remis à zéro sont remis à zéro à
tokyo que voilà et qu'il faudra essayer
de faire du mieux possible comme comme
on le fait sur n'importe quel objectif
qui se voit les championnats du monde
que ce soit les coupes du monde voilà
l'essai pilote là sont des habitués de
deux des grandes courses
et maintenant voilà il faudra juste se
centrer sur les jeux comme on le fait
sur n'importe quel autre n'importe quel
autre compétition dans la question rom 1
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
cgo
mais la maison se ferait ce serait c'est
ce que plutôt plutôt cool donc non mais
de profiter de tout mettre en place la
sur ces prochaines semaines pour arriver
au top au top de la forme et est rentré
rentrer avec une médaille
bon courage en tout cas à tous les deux
merci d'être intervenu dans cette
émission sur évidemment les performances
des pilotes de l'équipe de france aux jo
cet été je vous rappelle les dates des
jeux de tokyo
ils se dérouleront du 23 juillet au 8
août merci beaucoup
elle aussi hao jeux olympiques à cet été
maiva hamadouche licencié au boxing club
de saint quentin en yvelines avec la
team farrugia a gagné son ticket pour
tokyo dans le grand dôme de villebon sur
yvette la sportif de 31 ans a battu la
hongroise kata prix beauf qui au point
repêchage des moins de 60 kg à
l'occasion du tournoi de qualification
olympique
la professionnelle participera donc à
ses premiers à jeux olympiques à sera la
seule femme parmi les cinq qualifiés
français sur ses juges amoa d'aviron à
présent à 23 ans claire bové et fait
partie des plus grandes promesses de ce
sport en france être un musicien sied à
l'association sportive mantaise va
participer aux jeux olympiques de tokyo
à cet été avec l'équipe de france sans
portrait d'un mois alors aujourd'hui je
vous emmène pour une séance
d'entraînement avec moi c'est parti les
retrouver a toujours le sourire quand on
lui parle d'aviron la sportive de 23 ans
aujourd'hui en équipe de france a
commencé cette passion en cinquième avec
sa meilleure amie dans le club de meulan
les mureaux hardricourt pourtant ce
sport n'était pas sa discipline de
prédilection a préféré à l'époque le
triathlon
j'avoue que j'ai tout fait pour échoué
aux examens d'entrée pour la section
sportive mais finalement j'ai été prise
quand même et puis au début c'était pas
c'était juste pour être avec les copains
les copines et puis finalement ça a
commencé à bien plaire et puis j'ai
commencé à bien avancer aussi
ça aide pas mal les bons résultats car
bové aujourd'hui l'essentiel
associations sportives mantaise les
collectionne depuis ses débuts la
rameuse a notamment remporté la médaille
d'argent en championnat d'europe en deux
de couple poids légers en 2019 la
sportive a également été vice championne
du monde en moins de 23 ans est
championne de france à plusieurs
reprises ça fait quand même un petit
moment maintenant que que je m'entraîne
dur et donc ça fait du bien que les
efforts et paye mais je me souviens
encore d'être assise en minimes sur les
pontons des championnats de france avec
ma meilleure amie en disant un jour ben
on sera dans cette finale et on a réussi
à faire cette finale et à être
championne de france ensemble donc ça
c'est cool mais c'est vrai qu'au début
on s'est dit que ce serait un beau rêve
est finalement le beau rêve se réaliser
quoi un autre rêve pourrait se réaliser
cet été clair bové fait partie des
cadres de cette équipe de france
d'aviron qui s'envoleront pour tokyo la
rameuse a de grandes ambitions sur ce
rendez-vous un podium olympique
ce serait franchement c'est un beau rêve
on a les armes pour se battre dans la
catégorie et pour faire de belles choses
donc c'est un beau rêve mais
un petit peu réaliste quand même pour
préparer au mieux la compétition la
sportive à s'entraîner jusqu'au 15
juillet dans le jura à tokyo ses courses
se dérouleront du 26 au 30 juillet dans
la catégorie deux de couple femmes poids
légers en football l'euro a débuté
vendredi dernier avec la somptueuse
victoire de l'italie contre la turquie à
3 0 l'équipe de france elle fera son
entrée ce mardi 15 juin face à
l'allemagne les bleues qui ont reçu
jeudi dernier la vie d'emmanuel met des
manuels macron le président de la
république s'est rendu dans les yvelines
à clairefontaine là où se préparent les
hommes de didier deschamps
objectif les encourager ils en auront
bien besoin l'équipe de france figure
dans le groupe f du tournoi qui fait
office de poule de la mort en compagnie
de l'allemagne donc mais aussi du
portugal champion d'europe en titre et
de la hongrie les bleus se sont envolés
ce lundi depuis l'aéroport de vélizy
villacoublay en direction de munich pour
disputer ce premier match contre eux à
l'allemagne toujours en football matteo
à guendouzi ch pourrait signer à
l'olympique de marseille le milieu de
terrain originaire de poissy et est
actuellement sur ton contrat avec le
club anglais d'arsenal plaît énormément
aux dirigeants phocéens le joueur de 22
ans passé notamment par les jeunes du
paris saint-germain entre 2005 et 2014
serait sur les tablettes du duo semble
paoli longoria pour renforcer l'entrejeu
marseillais une offre évaluée entre 12
et 15 millions d'euros est à l'étude et
il pourrait signer dans les prochains
jours selon les dernières rumeurs
un mot de voile à présent louis burton
est actuellement engagés sur la course
dit ocean race europe avec son nouveau
bateau bureau vallée 3 laurent boli
teint est parti ce dimanche depuis
alicante en espagne en direction de
gênes en italie pour la troisième et
dernière étape de cette course pour cet
ultime test l'illinois tentera de
terminer dans le trio de tête de la
catégorie imoca il est pour l'instant en
bon dernier du classement à la cinquième
place sur cinq la fin de la course est
programmée ce mardi dans l'après midi on
continue par du golfe focus sur un livre
qui met en parallèle le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le
développement personnel le nom du livre
l'albatros parcours de vie pour nous
parler de ce livre nous avons avec nous
l'auteur jean christophe buchot à
bonsoir bonsoir michael alors vous êtes
coach consultant en stratégie surtout a
passionné de golf pourquoi avoir voulu
écrire ce livre
j'ai écrit ce livre parce que comme vous
le dites je suis passionné de golf je
sais pas si vous même d'ailleurs joué au
golf michael je joue un petit peu un
petit peu et est ce que vous avez joué
suffisamment pour vous rendre compte
qu'il y avait une école de vie derrière
des coups de golf et les 18 trous il a
espoir à 112 81 cents coups que l'on
fait au cours des 18 trous ah oui il y
en a beaucoup effectivement voilà donc
je crois que dès qu'on se met à jouer au
golf et plus on joue au golf puis on
s'aperçoit qu'on apprend beaucoup sur le
parcours et des choses qui peuvent nous
servir bien au delà du parcours
si vous voulez je crois que vraiment au
golf on développe des compétences qu'on
appelle des sources crise par exemple en
ressources humaines
c'est à dire en dehors des connaissances
théoriques on acquiert dans les écoles
et les connaissances techniques comme
dans les écoles de commerce ou ou en
médecine
à côté de ça pour réussir en entreprise
ou dans la vie il faut développer des
qualités humaines donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle des soeurs style c'est à dire un
savoir être un esprit d'équipé une
attitude positive
ces éléments là qui à côté des
connaissances techniques que l'on
acquiert qui nous permettent de mieux
performer ce que j'appelle performer
c'est-à-dire de réussira à faire au
mieux
c'est par une notion de forcément
d'excellence et faire au mieux de ses
compétences du moment et ça on acquiert
tous ces éléments-là par l'expérience du
jeu de golf
l'expérience du jeu de golf je vous
donnerai trois enseignements par exemple
et après qu'on pourrait développer
la preuve mon lift et 550 pages donc on
peut évidemment aller beaucoup plus loin
mais il le mco nous permet d'apprendre à
gérer au mieux nos émotions les émotions
dieu sait qu'on en vie puisque vous avez
joué quelques fois sur un parcours de
golf il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
frustration quand on joue au golf au
début donc je sais que je vends pas
beaucoup le golf en disant ça mais on a
comme on dit les trente premières années
au vol sont les plus difficiles
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de déchet
qu'au début on rate beaucoup plus de
coups qu'on n'en réussit et tout au long
de sa carrière gautschi on ratera
beaucoup de coûts y compris ils ont pris
les meilleurs
des meilleurs faut savoir preminger
disent qu'ils ne réussissent que six
coups dans une partie quand ils sont au
niveau professionnel
donc on doit gérer toutes ses
frustrations ses émotions où l'euphorie
quand on réussi un birdie ou un eagle il
ya une autorise alors qu'en fait pour
bien jouer il faut rester dans une
humeur stable ça c'est un premier
enseignement du golfe après vous allez
me dire c'est qu'on peut retrouver ça
dans d'autres sports la spécificité du
golfe c'est le temps de gamberge qui est
qui est beaucoup plus important que dans
d'autres sports puisque entre chaque
coup contrairement au tennis par exemple
il se passe facilement cinq minutes et
pourquoi avoir choisi le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
spécifiquement alors le golf mais parce
que si j'avais écrit le même ouvrage sur
le tennis j'aurais choisi roland garros
et il se trouve que vous avez la chance
dans les yvelines d'avoir à la fois le
clairefontaine et le stade de france du
golfe qui est l'albatros et c'est un
parcours mythique et il se trouve que
j'ai construit mon livre un petit peu
commun une série netflix en tout cas je
voulais que vérité avec 18 18 épisodes
et des personnalités importantes du
golfe qui interviennent comme des
personnages récurrents et qui racontent
leur parcours de vie et d'une donne tout
un tas de secret sur leur réussite et en
quoi le gosse leur a permis justement
d'accéder à ses réussites
donc je tenais pour pour cette histoire
à avoir le plus belle des écrins le plus
beau des écrins le plus beau des décors
et pour moi c'est évidemment l'albatros
qui est un parcours absolument mythique
puisqu'il a reçu la ryder cup en 2018 il
va recevoir le championnat du monde
amateur en 2022 ait les yeux les jeux
olympiques en 2024 donc
excusez du peu plus les open de france
tous les ans quand il ya pas de
confinement
donc c'est forcément le choix s'arrêter
obligatoirement sur sur l'albatros et il
se trouve dans le golf national qui a
également deux autres parcours l'aigle
et puis loiselet pour les débutants
alors vous avez interrogé dans votre
livre plusieurs personnalités du monde
du golf
c'était important d'avoir leur réaction
il ya notamment la réaction de pascal
grizot le président la fédération
française de golf il ya également
d'autres personnes qui travaillent
autour du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est important d'avoir cette ces
réactions la wii parce que eh bien ma
propre voix je raconte que matt ma
propre philosophie de la préparation
mentale et de la stratégie
mais à côté de mes conseils j'avais
envie également effectivement de
l'appuyer sur les parcours de golf de
deux champions comme thomas levet ou
patricia meunier lebouc et de cadres de
la fédération dont pascal grizot le
président jean louis charon le président
de du mandat précédent
hubert chesneau qui est le dessinateur
architecte de ce parcours et ils
apportent ils enrichissent évidemment le
propos de leur propre histoire est
forcément plus de tout un tas de clôture
il ya énormément de gens comme je vous
disais à intervenir dans cette histoire
et ils reviennent dans les différents
épisodes je vous l'expliquais un petit
peu comme des personnages je ne sais pas
c'est pas 18 trous 18 interview c'est
ses 18 trous dix-huit chapitres 72
stratégie à chaque achat qu à chaque
coup il ya un personnage qui intervient
qui révèle un secret et qui enrichit
forcément tout ça donc la structure est
un petit peu complexe mais j'essaie de
faire en sorte qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient vivantes un petit peu c'est pour
ça que je veux parler de séries netflix
merci à vous d'être intervenu dans cette
émission le livre l'albatros parcours de
vie et à retrouver aux éditions amphora
mais on va maintenant sinon je les
réalise monté par mon attachée de presse
je serai en signature au golf national
sera l'occasion pour les téléspectateurs
de venir poursuivre ce débat avec moi le
26 et 27 juin
voilà le rendez vous est pris en tout
cas merci beaucoup filmant alors on va
maintenant parler un rugby à partir de
la rentrée prochaine le club de plaisir
va ouvrir une académie à destination des
jeunes de 16 à 23 ans des journées de
détection et et a programmé la semaine
dernière au stade robert barran ils
étaient nombreux à se prêter à
l'exercice en montage d'arthur huyghe
une dizaine de jeunes joueurs un seul
objectif intégrer la future académie de
rugby a plaisir à la rentrée prochaine
ces rugbymen ont bravé les chaleurs de
ce mercredi 9 juin pour se soumettre à
une journée de détection organisée par
le club pour reconnaître les meilleurs
des tests de haut niveau ont été mises
en place
alors là il y aura plusieurs plusieurs
séquences ayant une séquence physique
avec des tests de vitesse et ensuite y
aura des séquences de jeu de
manipulation voilà qu'on puisse observer
la technique et le sens tactique des
joueurs quoi pendant le jeu et des
choses qu'on voit très très vite
effectivement après il ya des choses il
faut qu'on mette en place un peu un peu
de jeu de mouvement pour voir un peu les
qualités de deux des joueurs et des
joueuses
ces tests vont permettre de sélectionner
des joueurs de 16 à 23 ans du
département des yvelines au total ils
seront une vingtaine de joueurs et
joueuses intégré cette structure au mois
de septembre elle sera encadrée par le
club les premiers plus d'heures de rugby
aux sportifs on va travailler toute la
semaine en fait on va leur proposer un
planning hebdomadaire avec 2 5 à 12
heures en plus de rugby individuelles en
plus de leur séance collective
une formule qui a séduit les joueurs
présents sur place c'est une opportunité
pour en faire plus et être avec les amis
y a plus d'accompagnement pense que ça
peut amener un autre niveau auquel on
que auquel on joue déjà ça peut être une
bonne opportunité je trouve pour me
perfectionner rugby enfin on peut
toujours s'améliorer et puis
l'accompagnement à l'air d'être plutôt
sympa comme ça nous a déjà été un peu
expliqué donc ça peut être une bonne une
bonne expérience
si j'ai détecté à un patient et a hâte
de voir la suite à une deuxième journée
de détection était organisée ce samedi
12 juin au stade robert barran de
plaisir course à pied malgré de
nombreuses annulations à cause de la
crise sanitaire l'eco trail de paris
devrait bien se dérouler le 3 juillet
avec plusieurs courses au départ des
yvelines le seul gros changement devrait
concerner le 80 km au départ de lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
la course ne se terminera pas au premier
étage de la tour eiffel car la dame de
fer n'accueillera pas de public avant le
16 juillet l'arrivée se fera finalement
devant le pont d'iéna au pied de la tour
eiffel au rendez vous devrait tout de
même attiré plusieurs milliers de
participants
et on termine par un moa d'apnée andy
cabreira avila l'apnéiste franco-cubain
de la piscine de saint cyr l'école a
réussi un nouveau défi l'a parcouru 52
km en apnée en remontant la surface
entre hyères et ses îles pour
sensibiliser à la cause des océans et la
réaliser ce périple entre le 5 et le 11
juin chaque fois le sportif de 50 ans a
plongé à une profondeur de 25 mètres
pour amasser plusieurs kilos de déchets
et entre à d'autres défis de ce
type dans les prochaines années dans les
yvelines et à la piscine de saint cyr
l'école c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv à
[Musique]